there's a life lesson in this movie
sometimes crime goes bad and sometimes
movies about crime yeah they go bad too
[Music]
30 minutes or less now 30 minutes or
less is directed by the guy who directed
Zombieland so right there I was like
awesome and Jesse Eisenberg was also in
Zombieland so it's like that guy and
Jesse Eisenberg are kind of like
DiCaprio and Scorsese only you know not
like that at all and Jesse Eisenberg
isn't really going anywhere in life he's
a pizza delivery guy his friend from
Parks and Recreation whose name I really
don't know he has more going form in
life he's a substitute teacher but
really the coolest thing about that is
you get summers off otherwise that job
but pretty much suck ass too and then
you have Danny McBride and his friend
whose name I don't know I don't know
everyone's name but we're also nowhere
in life and dynamic bride's dad is like
a millionaire so Danny McBride gets the
idea from this stripper that he should
hire someone to kill his dad so Danny
McBride can get his inheritance so Danny
McBride's friend makes a bomb which they
strapped to Jesse Eisenberg's chest
that's also like alright Jesse Eisenberg
you now have 10 hours to get us a
hundred thousand dollars so I can hire a
hitman to kill my father so I can get my
inheritance and if Jesse Eisenberg fails
well he goes boom and then our 80 minute
long movie ensues so this movie had a
ridiculous premise I was like it's gonna
be hilarious misdirected by the guy who
directed zombie land cells like it's
gonna be hilarious and the movie was
kind of funny in parts it was just so
disjointed like for the first half it
was choppy didn't know where it wanted
to go or even what kind of movie it
wanted to be and then in the second half
of the movie it picks up and becomes
better with 40 minutes left in the movie
but still it just wasn't enough it's
almost like the guy who wrote this movie
was in script writing college and he was
struggling he didn't know what to do so
we had five roommates so he just
cherry-picked from their scripts and he
put a script together and now we have
this and I don't know what it is there's
something about that guy that's Jesse
Eisenberg's friend there's something
about his voice it just annoys me I
sounded like one season scrubs and I was
like that there's something about that
guy I don't like them be kinda has its
high voice like this uh which is funny
because some people have said that about
me they're like dude there's something
about your voice I hate and if it's
anything like that guy I'm like oh I get
it now alright that's cool one cool fan
came out of this movie though the
coolest part of the movie says car chase
scene in which the music playing to it
is that eighty song the heat is on I was
like dude when I get home I am totally
playing burnout to that song which is
funny because I came home and I started
filming videos but I will play burnout
to that song cuz it just looks awesome
silver lining people we're looking for a
silver lining so in the end I had some
funny one-liners and had a few funny
scenes but the movie was either boring
or disjointed or all over the place all
around just kind of forgettable in the
end you're not going to remember it in
t-minus five hours that's the time I'll
give it five hours to okay movie
fanatics favorite robbery scene of any
movie ever could be robbing anything
doesn't matter comment below let me know
and as always you can like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]